we are now asking a question that a year
ago i would not have been asking and
that question is has cnn decided to
become fox news
what
david what are you talking about sir
please explain
well this all started
as a result of the
new ceo of cnn
uh or or president i guess they call him
chris licht has been selected as the
next president of cnn we learned this in
february of 2022 and immediately after
this was the case and we learned about
this
we started to learn about chris licht we
learned that he created morning joe he
revamped cbs this morning he revitalized
this is cnn's own words he revitalized
the late show with stephen colbert
and
he was selected back in february
to take control of cnn
one of the statements one of the big
headlines very quickly became
cnn management is intent
on changing perception of the network
that's from abc news
uh just a few days ago a couple weeks
ago
and
as we have started to see
a number of resignations from cnn
licht reportedly told cnn staffers don't
call the big lie the big lie anymore
saying that sounds like a democratic
slogan so trump's attempt to steal the
election that he didn't win
don't call it the big lie anymore and we
have started to see
some walkouts from some relatively high
profile correspondence at cnn john
harwood
brian stelter jeffrey toobin john cooper
tweeted i decided to boycott cnn as soon
as the network began its shift to the
right it was a tough decision since i've
been a devout cnn viewer since i was in
my 20s if i wanted to watch right-wing
propaganda i'd watch fox so for now it's
only msnbc for me
cnn anchor brianna keeler took some heat
when she tweeted
after joe biden's thursday speech last
week which we covered quote whatever you
think of this speech the military is
supposed to be apolitical positioning
marines in uniform behind president
biden for a political speech flies in
the face of that it's wrong when
democrats do it it's wrong with
republicans do it well trump did it too
presidents do it and you don't always
hear the same criticism in fact here's a
picture of trump from 2019 doing the
exact same thing now okay bry brianna
keeler says she's against it in all
cases but they didn't really talk about
it that i was able to find in 2019 so
this was another
little data point
in some of our viewers and others saying
there just is a shift in feel about
what's going on at cnn
recently
cnn also made the decision to hire a guy
named john miller
john miller top intel official
award-winning journalist and
best-selling author writes cnn
added to the network's roster of expert
analysts added as a chief law
enforcement and intelligence analyst
well
miller is a guy who lied under oath
about nypd policy of surveilling muslims
in the post-9 11 era
it's kind of absurd to say
we are hiring this guy as a law
enforcement analyst so a number of
different red flags increasingly raising
questions about what is happening here
at cnn and i want to remind people of
the most important aspect to all of this
you know for so long there's these
phrases that people just repeat repeat
repeat fox is left and cnn and msnbc are
on the right
and as i've reminded people many times
before
fox is on the right i'm sorry did i say
that backwards fox is on the right cnn
and msnbc are on the left i'm now
thinking i might have gotten that wrong
before what i meant to say in case i
didn't is fox is on the right
cnn msnbc are on the left and as i've
said before
fox is on the right
in a completely unhinged propagandistic
way
msnbc editorially has taken a
center-left perspective it's a
democratic party perspective it's not
progressive and cnn
plays it closer to the middle while
certainly having an anti-trump bias i
think that's perfectly fine but
fundamentally these are all
corporate media outlets with profit as
their primary goal
and that should not
it should then not surprise us
when a change in leadership at cnn
potentially signals a significant
editorial shift as well because these
organizations fundamentally are there to
make money that's what they're there for
and you know we've been accused of the
same oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad but of
course that's really kind of a joke
right i mean we're funded directly by
our audience
because we are a progressive show these
corporate media outlets are much more
similar than they are different even if
the type of propaganda you see is not
the same so at the end of the day it's
not a major shock that if cnn perceives
it can make more money by having higher
ratings by making this shift in the
direction of the right that they would
do it we'll see in the next few months
and particularly in their coverage of
the 2022 midterms how it all shakes out
remember on september 19th
we are doing a massive membership
discount if you'd like to be notified
about this discount just get on my
newsletter at davidpakman.com